1996年,比爾·蓋茲上了David Letterman的深夜節目。
Letterman問他電腦還會不會有我們現在想不到的下一步。
那是30年前
這兩個禮拜
比爾蓋茲至少上了四個節目
一直在敲AI的警鐘
這一集我們把其中三場剪在一起
9月15號泰晤士報的Podcast
9月27號NBC的Meet the Press
還有9月29號紐約時報的
Azra Klein訪談
每一段是哪一場
我們都會先講
剛剛那段Letterman
就是Azra在訪談一開頭放給她看的
接著問她
從那時候到今天中間發生了什麼
and I challenged them,
hey,
getting a perfect grade,
which is a five,
第二次震撼
我們換到9月15號
泰晤士報那場來聽
回到9月29號,Ezra Klein那場。
這就是我們不需要新的法律
這是個人的職負責人的角色
不可以發佈一種
沒有準備發佈的產品
你怎麼看待這個問題
有沒有一種產品
比AI的能力
能力
殺亡數百億人,這現在存在,能夠進行
資產攻擊,把所有資產帳戶都刪除,關閉電子
鏈,這現在存在,我們知道這是實際情況,而
原因是,因為有缺乏意志的人
可以用AI來使它做這些事情,
而這不是AI,你知道,在未來,控制問題
Azure接著替黃仁勳那一邊問,出了事,公司自己就會被告,市場的誘因還不夠嗎?
在其他領域,
我們是否只是說,
嘿,
放下你的藥物,
沒有FDA,
沒有航空安全組織,
沒有車用座帶的要求,
我們只是用利益法律來嘗試保護人們,
你知道,
哦,
你,
你購買
我說,
我們創建了一個社會 that tries to keep people safe not by saying oh,
我們可以抵押
the harms here,
and you say there's filtering,
there's not filtering,
這不是 filter
and this exists today,
so no,
there is no filtering.
是任何種類的
比如說
你殺了100萬人
你要用法庭法庭
我根本就不敢說
這不是我的看法
但這是特朗普的看法
這是David Sachs的看法
至某程度上
這是Jensen Huang的看法
所以這就是
我和你討論的地方
因為這就是美國的
管治看法
現在的美國
在企業外,
AI的危險的知識非常低。
你可以說是學術,你可以說是思考機構,
你可以說是政策人員,政治家。
我能說得很大聲的是,
你不可以依靠企業來自制制。
我認為這真是太可怕了
我的唯一的問題是
我們要等待
一個大型車禍
與一個生物攻擊
與一個大型車禍
然後,這些討論安全
在這些模式中必須進行,
以緩慢這些情況的機會
多次發生
還是我們能夠
證明這些事情
在4億萬人前
你剛才寫了一篇文章關於AI的風險,這對你來說是一個很大的跳躍。
我讀了你過去的課題,在2023年7月的課題中,它是《AI的風險是真實的,但能夠管理的嗎?》
I think,
我覺得你處於一個
etc. Is that fair?
不,
最重要的是,
我們總是說,
當我們跨過這些階段時,
我們將會集中整個社會,
因為我們將會創造最危險的事物。
這讓核武似乎是一切。
我們說我們會集中,而我們跨過了這些階段時,那裡就有完整的沉默。
他上了NBC的Meet the Press,主持人問得更直接。
引起一百萬死亡
雖然100%是很難得到的
但從來沒有任何人
用最新的智能技術
能夠使用這麼強大的武器
而且很棒的是
與企業討論的討論
還有一個討論是
是否能夠使用殺殺轉換,是這樣的實際性嗎?
殺殺轉換是個奇怪的事情。
殺殺轉換並不是足夠的。
我們還沒有到一個狀態,
他們能夠自行抓住電腦,
並不能被關閉。
這種討論,
我認為這就顯示了
各種各樣的技術人員的不技能性
我永遠不想說
我對殺人轉換
但是你不...
當你試圖阻止
這種糟糕的行為
你需要理解
以及記錄
所在的事情
所以殺人轉換
就不可能阻止這種壞事
你也認為
特朗普最近發佈了
AI 帶領全球 破壞人類和其他壞事
是一個謊言
您認為這些謊言
對於AI 具有可能的生存風險
對人類來說是一個謊言嗎
不 這並不是一個謊言
但他最初的反應就是這樣
他會聽聽
他希望保護美國人
很多人都不明白
A.I. 要各國一起管,總得有人帶頭。
回到9月15號,泰晤士報那場。
回到9月29號
Ezra Klein那場
還有一大段在講工作
Ezra問她
放射科醫師沒有少
工程師也還是很搶手
為什麼你認為
AI真的會大規模搶走工作
製造更多工作 than it's destroyed
the demand for the skill sets
even just to build the data centers
is very very high
we have a you know
a reasonably low unemployment rate
the superiority of these systems
is subject to a threshold
where you have to believe
that it's incredibly reliable
you know if you're going to have your
tele sales or telesupport capability
你需要確保它的準確度比人類的更佳
所以我們實際上超過了這層標準的職業
甚至我認識很多人在過去的經歷中
不想使用AI來研發
但研發者認識到
that most applications
can be developed very inexpensively
We will in the next few years
cross over those thresholds
for accounting, legal work
tele-sales, tele-support
很多人拿Javons
不論反駁它
東西變便宜
需求就會變多
工作最後會漲回來
As soon as you complete the entire task
it doesn't matter
that there's demand elasticity
that goes into the token budget
不涉及人工薪水額
一些這些東西的價值比人工勞動的價值還要低。
因此,當你跌穿與人工智能機構的線路,
包括白色臉和人工智能機構,
你會破壞職業,
並且沒有高層面。
在過去的創新中,
如果你有汽車,沒問題,
讓我們在迪士尼建造,
並且在那裡擁有很多人。
但在廣泛經濟中,
人們說會有增加的職業,我不明白他們的想法,他們不應該理解我們正在進行的改善方式。
我們沒有在美國的生產業務中發生浪費,
對嗎?我們發展了我們實際的生產,
但很多的職業在沙灘中,
有些職業在自動化中,
但是我們在1960年代的美國,
我們沒有在1960年代的生產業務中發生少量的總職業。
經濟變化了
是的,人類的智慧變成了少量的元素
是的
這總是關於少量的元素
對
當你把人類的智慧變成少量的元素
實際上,你在24小時一天的工作中
更多的讀書,每個語言都知道
你移動的少量就沒有了
所以你覺得人類的少量
不再存在嗎
稱之為少量
所以你的答案
對你來說是一個非常堅定的想法
就是我們應該負責AI的使用
為什麼和如何?
假設,工作人員在聯繫聯繫公司的聯繫公司中
在聯繫公司的聯繫公司中收入,
所以聯繫工作人員支持聯繫工作人員。
如果您讓工作人員擔任聯繫公司的聯繫公司,
為什麼您如此擔憂人工勞動,
而不讓聯繫公司也收入聯繫公司?
他另一個提議
是事先把托育、長照這類工作畫出來
保留給人做
他叫他人類保留職業
Ezra說
你對工作比很多實驗室裡的人還悲觀
他講了一個故事
主角是Amazon
找真人
做零碎小工作的平臺
Mechanical Turk
那是有趣的,當我告訴這個人,
有些人認為是主要的經濟學家在看AI,
他說,如何能夠仍然存在俄羅斯,
如果AI正如你所說,
我說,它不會。
一週後,它完全關閉了。
嗯,是的,知識的融合,
你必須說,
你不覺得很驚訝嗎?
你越知道,越擔心。
9月27號NBC那場的最後主持人問他
希望他的孩子跟孫子未來是什麼樣子
1996年他說
讓電腦思考幾乎毫無進展
30年後
他一個節目接一個節目遞獎
要大家趕在大災難之前
先把防護跟監控裝進每一個AI
三場訪談加起來兩個多小時
泰晤士報那場
他還回答了
AI是不是泡沫
Ezra那場則講了
AI會怎麼影響小孩的學習
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多